[APPLAUSE]
GINO MICACCHI: Hello, everybody.
Thank you, Nico, and
the Google Play team
for giving me the toughest
spot in the agenda.
We are all coming
back from heavy lunch.
So it's going to be
difficult to engage you.
But since it's a session
about engagement, let's try.
So since we have
very little time,
I don't want to spend too
much time on this slide.
You can research about us.
You can download our app.
But the one thing I want you
to remember about ABA English
is very simple.
We teach English,
which is actually
a very simple sentence that
highlights the complexity what
we do.
[? Because, see, ?] when you try
to work improving engagement,
sometimes you feel the barrier
of maybe not trying to really
achieve the final result that
your user is trying to reach.
To put it simple, the
final goal for our users
is to learn a language.
Can we really measure the fact
that the user is progressing
in learning language
with the classic metrics
that we have for engagement?
So basically, a
few years ago, we
were asking ourself
this question,
is quantitative data
enough for us to measure
the efficiency of our methods?
Is stickness, or one day,
seven day retention, the right
metric for us to measure that?
And I want to ask
you a question.
I think we are all
obsessed with metrics.
How many of you have checked
your KPIs in the last 24 hours?
Oh, come on, guys,
you should do better.
The other question for
you is, how many of you
had a meaningful conversation
with one of your customers
in the last month?
I'm actually surprised.
But see, this is the point.
We came to the realization
that quantitative data
was able to tell us
where the problem was.
But to really go
further, we needed
to go to the real source.
And so we decided to change
completely our mentality
and to really put
our student first.
This has been a
long journey for us.
And we are still halfway
through to become
a real customer-centric company.
But still, it's a journey
I want to share with you.
And the first step
that, for us, was
very important to go
through this journey
was to really have
management commitment.
It is very hard if
management doesn't believe
in this statement,
to be able to become
a customer-centric company.
The second thing we had to do--
luckily, we had the support.
But the second
thing we had to do
was to basically shock
the organization.
And to do that, we
literally brought people out
of the building.
Yes, literally we took people
from different departments--
engineering, marketing,
product, of course.
We went on the street.
And we started interviewing
potential customers.
It's something I invite you to
do also because, for us, it was
a very mind blowing experience.
And the results we got
back from that experience
was that we stopped
discussing what we thought
was better for our user.
And the conversation slowly
started becoming more oriented
to what the user will do,
what our user will need,
in this moment.
Sometimes you don't
need to go that far.
You have probably the answer
already in the [INAUDIBLE]..
Your customer support
team is in the front line.
They know already what are
the main issues of the users.
So simply ask them.
Another important step for us
was to introduce user research.
Now, we do research every week.
We have users coming
every week in the office.
We do remote surveys.
We do a lot of stuff that
allows us to have two ways
communication with our users.
And another very important
part is trying to avoid silos.
Sometimes this information,
like in the case of customer
support, is already available.
It's only compartmentalized
into department,
as someone else said.
You need to make this
information available
if you really want to focus
on customers to improve
engagement.
And we brought this up
into our development cycle.
So basically, you can read a
lot about dual-track agile.
I highly recommend an
article from, more or less,
10 years ago from Marty Cagan
from the Silicon Valley Product
Group that explains a lot
about the methodology.
But the basic concept is you
have basically two tracks.
In discovery, you try to
figure out what to build.
In delivery, you deliver
what you already validated.
And so having our process,
our development process,
considering these two
different moments,
they are both tentative
moments, was key for us
because, in discovery,
we use techniques
like design springs,
prototyping, research
to quickly validate hypotheses,
to formulate and validate
hypotheses.
And thanks to the
qualitative data
we got from this first phase,
we can more confidently
move into delivery.
Also, engineering teams are
more happy at this point
because their probability
of what they are building
in the delivery track is higher
because we already validated
key hypotheses in discovery.
So to give you an
idea and trying
to also jump into a
real life example of how
we had to leverage qualitative
data in combination
with quantitative ones, look
at this very simple step
in our old onboarding.
So again, we teach English.
So in the onboarding
stage, we were asking users
to tell us what was their
initial level of English.
If we look at only
quantitative data,
we weren't losing so
many users in this step.
Actually, barely nobody was
dropping off at this point.
Every user was
selecting a level.
But you know what?
When we started in analyzing
their sentiment in this stage,
we discovered that many users
were actually frustrated.
How do I assess my
level of English?
And how this is going to
work out at the end for me
in the app?
What we found out
is that, eventually,
the fact that
users were randomly
selecting level of
English in this stage
led to abandonment later on.
We had users that were
overestimating their level.
And they were basically facing
with too difficult exercises,
and vice versa, users were
underestimating themselves
and finding the
exercises we were
proposing too easy for them.
So we worked in a solution.
We prototyped
different solutions
to try to address this issue.
And at the end we
went for one that
was kind of counterintuitive.
We created a way longer
funnel during the onboarding.
Now we ask users to
take a level test.
Yes, we still have easy path.
If you're a beginner, if you
want to skip the onboarding,
then you can still do that.
But our new happy path for
users onboarding the app
goes through a level test.
And again, it's
counterintuitive because we
were adding many steps in
the onboarding process.
You will think, OK,
many more steps,
the funnel will be longer.
And you will lose users.
Well, it wasn't that the case.
In fact, what we saw
overall, with these
and all other experiments
that we did on the onboarding,
is that we achieved double
activation in our app.
And again, if we were only to
focus on the quantitative data,
we were never going to discover
where the real problem was.
So again, what we
learn, as a company,
is that you need to
go to the source.
You need to talk
with your customers,
eventually even going
out of the building.
Complement quantitative
data with qualitative data.
Bring it into your
full development cycle.
Make it practice for you
to have this feedback
into your development cycle.
And ultimately, experiment.
Experiment a lot
because, at the end,
it's what really is
going to help you
find the successful solutions.
Thank you.
I'm going to pass
the baton to Rishit.
I hope I said it right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RISHIT JHUNJHUNWALA:
Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Rishit from Truecaller.
So what is Truecaller?
Quick view on that.
Truecaller is a
communication app
that improves not only your
calls but also your messages.
We've been around for a while.
We're headquartered in Sweden.
The main thing to
get from this is
that our context is that we are
operating at a certain scale.
We were able to do
some of these things
because we operate
at that scale.
So talking about
engagement, the first thing
is how did we measure
the engagement.
There are a bunch of
metrics that we can use.
We looked at sessions
per DAU, time spent.
But then we stuck
to DAU/MAU ratio.
This was the North Star
metric that we're using now.
This is the email that
goes out to all employees
across the company
every single day.
We do have feature level
metrics as well, of course,
for engagement.
But we thought this was a good
overall, overarching metric
to track.
It also gave us a comparison
with some of the other apps.
So we said, let's
stick to this one.
So that's how we measure it.
But what did we do to
increase our engagement?
So the first thing
was we realized-- we
made this mistake many times.
As we were launching
new things, we
realized that a lot of
our users didn't even
know that we had launched
some of these things.
So we made the
effort introducing
some of these features to them.
We also ensured
that we got users
to upgrade to the latest
version of the app, which
was spoken about in the
last session as well.
This made a huge
difference to us.
Here's another example
of education that we use.
We sent out a notification.
It's slightly contextual so
that we don't spam our users.
The other one thing that
we did, which I don't think
is spoken about enough--
it did come up in the
earlier session-- was speed.
If you can improve
your app launch speed--
just that exact metric,
app launch speed--
you can easily get a
few percentage points
at the very least
of your engagement.
Faster apps are much
easier to engage with.
And that's what users love.
So please focus on speed if
that's something you can do.
And please focus on
your app open speed.
And then we looked at, how is it
that we can add more features?
Where should we look at for
more features for engagement?
And this is about going deeper
into your existing use case.
So we were already there in
the user's life for calls.
When you get an incoming
call, we showed you caller ID.
Or we told you it was spam.
And that's great.
So we said, how can we
participate even further
into that calling experience?
So that's when we built the
dialing experience insight.
So we went deeper into
the calling space.
The other thing we did was,
while you can go deeper
as well, we also looked at
slightly adjacent parallel use
cases.
So we were already
in the calling space.
And we were doing really well.
Users love what we were doing.
And we said that similar
problem that we're
solving in the
calling space actually
exists in the messaging
space as well.
So maybe we can go horizontal
and introduce messaging.
And I think this was
one of our biggest gains
in engagement, that
we went horizontal.
And our users loved that.
The other thing we
found was, all our apps,
everyone has some user
base and some community
that is already using your app.
Use that community to further
create engagement in your apps.
So we had features
like tagging, which
is on the screen,
commenting, spam reporting.
We took all of the
community generated content.
And we put this
back into the app.
So we actually
showed other users
that this number
has 56 spam reports.
And this many people
have tagged it as this.
And that actually
gave this feeling
to the rest of our users
that the app is alive
and it's active and it's
meant to be engaged with.
So our community
engagement actually
drove further
engagement as well.
All of this resulted in
really good gains for us
when we focused on
it, 30% increase
in that DAU/MAU ratio
North Star metric for us.
So that's great.
A lot of things went well.
30% increase, I got a
pat on my back as well.
But we were hurt in
many different ways.
And here are some
examples of that.
The first one was--
so we educated our users.
We pushed them to learn
new features that we have.
But we really annoyed our users.
We were hammered in the
app store for our ratings
and reviews.
And we had to pause
our a roadmap to focus
on some of these things,
and that really hurt us.
So be careful, when
you're educating users,
that you don't go overboard.
Keep track of these
things closely.
Also, what happened was, while
we were focused on this North
Star metric, we started
ignoring the key stats that
are available on Android
Vitals that was there
in the earlier session.
Specifically, crash
rate, wakelocks--
these things hurt us also.
Uninstall rates went up.
Our ratings went down.
So always, when you're
adding new stuff,
please make sure
you're tracking Android
Vitals as well because
we've learned the hard way
that it really
makes a difference.
The third one is--
I mean you can obsess about this
metric, any metric, some North
Star metric for your app.
But don't get obsessed,
like don't make your roadmap
obsessed with that metric
because what will then
start happening is, you'll
forget that users actually
don't give a shit
about your engagement.
They care about
their life and how
you're improving their life.
You have to keep adding stuff
that adds value to your users.
Otherwise, your competitors
will go ahead of you.
Where do you want to take
your user strategically,
you will lose out
on those aspects.
So I think the
theme of this talk
is exactly what I should end
with, that you should do less.
Do it better.
And I think that's what will
likely get you more engagement.
With that, I will hand
over to Timur from BADOO.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMUR GARIFZYANOV:
Hello, everyone.
Thank you, Gino and Rishit,
for great presentation.
My name is Timur.
I'm from BADOO.
To give you a little bit more
context, BADOO is not one app,
BADOO is a group of dating apps.
One of our biggest brands is
Badoo, obviously, and Bumble.
But we also have Chappy, which
is like a dating app for gays,
and Lumen, which is
dating before for seniors,
like over 50-- so a
lot of different brands
with the same dating
mechanic inside.
Our businesses are huge.
We have one billion votes
placed per day in our group.
We have 460 million users
registered around the apps.
So we are, by far, the biggest
dating group in the world.
And we have 300,000
users registered daily.
So engagement and how to make
engagement smart and doing
more by less is in our hearts.
And it's what's driving
our business forward.
So what I decided
to do is to give you
some examples of the features,
which we launched recently,
and how they affected
our KPIs and how,
by looking differently
in these KPIs,
you can take
different decisions.
And I want to start with
feature, which is sending
[INAUDIBLE] hearts in chats.
So chat is our
core functionality.
We have chats in
all of our apps.
And we decided
probably users have
a problem with
sending the message
like, we're spending too
much time thinking about what
should be sent, like
how we should approach
with people first.
And we wanted to give
them easy experience.
We said, OK, let's give them
this one button, like hearts.
And you're just
sending this heart.
And you invite a person
to a conversation.
Great feature.
We launched this one.
Results were quite
controversial.
So obviously, a lot of
people sending these chats.
Like, the number of messages
now ecosystem rose for like 20%,
like everyone sending
chats to everyone.
Everyone initiated chat easily.
But when we started to dig
deep into these metrics,
we find out that reply
rates for these messages
was ridiculously low.
So for males, compared to normal
messages, it's about 6% down.
For females, they don't
respond to these messages.
Like, they're ignoring this one.
So obviously we don't like the
people ignoring the messages.
We don't like people--
we're not focusing
on initiating new chats.
We're focusing on
the meaningful chats.
And our main metrics,
like female retention,
started to go down.
Females not only didn't like
to reply to these messages,
but they didn't like
this flooding of hearts
so much that they
were leaving the app.
So we decided to iterate on this
one and launch a new feature.
Like instead of giving you easy
access to sending a message,
what if we will go
backwards and actually
we'll disallow you
to send a message,
and make it much, much harder.
So we launched a feature which
is called bad openers blocker.
So if we will see that you're
sending some bad message,
like "hey," or
"hi," it's saying,
OK, this one message
is probably bad.
And this one is not open,
very good conversation.
The results were obvious.
This feature was
launched on Bumble,
which have a unique mechanics,
where it's only females can
initiate the chats.
Obviously this feature dropped
down the initiating chats
ratio, like 6% of females
initiating the chats.
But the reply rate for these
messages rose like 14%.
And we have this metric which
is called meaningful chats.
It's like how many messages were
sent, what was the reply rate.
It's given us an overall
score of quality of a chat.
It's over 7%.
So by sending less
messages, we are actually
improving the ecosystem
for our users,
by actually sending more
meaningful messages,
and exchanging in more
meaningful conversations.
I will jump for more
complex examples.
And the first one
is push messages
controlled by algorithm.
So [INAUDIBLE] have a
very interesting topic
about that sometimes you don't
know are you [INAUDIBLE] users?
Are you annoying enough?
Like where is this borderline
between being annoying
and notify enough users?
Because we want
users to be notified
about the important
events in our system.
So we decided that probably the
humans and the manual approach
is very hard for this one.
So what if we'll ask a
computer or machine learning
algorithm to control this one?
And we wrote a machine
learning algorithm, basically
with statistics.
We gathered the
data about should we
send these messages right now?
You probably already
have enough messages.
Or probably you don't
And based on this data,
we decided, should you
be notified about
this event right now,
or we should postpone this one?
So we launched this
feature recently,
and the results was
quite surprising.
For males we dropped like
total number of messages, 30%.
For females, we more
than halved the number
of messages we sent for females.
Obviously it means that for some
of them we were not [? over ?]
[? notifying, ?] but
borderline annoying.
And interesting fact
that although we
send less messages for females,
like we notify them less.
And in our industry
obviously, retention
is always linked to
the number of messages,
like number of push
notifications, number
of users you return back.
But what we learned is that
by sending less messages,
we actually retain,
and we actually
return back to more females.
They're more inclined
to return back.
Another one is
machine algorithm.
Obviously like with
dating, matching
is our core service,
core functionality.
All of our apps have
a matching game.
Like when you match
with people, you vote.
You show interest.
You say that I'm not interested.
And if both of you are
interested, this is a match.
And we open the conversation
functionality for you.
So for the last
couple months we were
focusing on this
poor experience,
like how we can
improve this one.
What is the main
metric for this one?
For a long time our metric
was total number of matches,
or number of matches per user.
But we said that probably
it's not the right metric.
Probably we should focus not
on generating more matches,
but to distribute them better,
or to balance the activity
better.
So we launched
the new algorithm.
And results in some
countries-- obviously
we operate in 170 markets.
Some markets [INAUDIBLE] better.
Some markets
slightly less better.
After launching
the new algorithm,
total number of
matches wasn't changed.
So from the perspective
of these KPIs,
it was like a failed experiment.
We spent like half a year
and achieved nothing.
But when we started
to look broader,
on the broader topic,
what we noticed
is that actually 20% of
users now have match.
Obviously if you're
focusing on the total number
or matches per
user, you can have
one user with 10 matches
and another user with 0.
[INAUDIBLE] The
median must be 5.
Or average would be 5.
So obviously we generated
more matches for the users
without them.
So now more users in our
ecosystem have matched.
And 50% more of them
have a yes vote,
which is sometimes
people vote yes on you
and you don't vote yes on them.
But this can happen.
But still, they generate
more matches, more yes votes.
And we generate
engagement for them.
We generate events for them.
So why it's successful
from this perspective?
So, again, what we
learned, and what
we have seen from these
examples is that you not only
need to focus on some KPIs.
You need to focus deep
on what these KPIs bring
into your ecosystem,
how these KPIs translate
into your ecosystem, like what
is the meaningful KPIs for you.
I have many, many more examples.
I chose only four because I
have a very, very short amount
of time.
If you want to discuss,
I would be somewhere
near a coffee shop.
Please join me.
Let's discuss, and I
will share with you more.
Thank you, everyone,
for your attention.
Going back to Nico.
[APPLAUSE]